foreign
let's go to Nikki in chai town in
Chicago what up Nikki
hi what's up
um not much I'm excited to get to talk
to you and get your perspective on some
situations that I'm going with right now
very cool thanks for your trust I'm
grateful for you what's up thanks
um so I am dealing with a little bit of
uh animosity and resentment towards my
new husband's ex-wife
and I was kind of hoping to get your uh
perspective on how to just cope with
that
wow okay
um tell me about it
so my husband and I have been together
for two years and married for two months
and between the two of us we have five
daughters
um so we are in a five daughters yeah
yeah
hey have your have your husband call the
show I just want to hug him
I just want to hug him yeah yeah he's
amazing actually uh he met you a few
years back uh during the entree
Leadership Summit so she told me to tell
his old friend John hi hello and he
didn't lead with hey there's six women
in my house
at least get him a boy dog or something
all right so we have a boy dog he
insists that the animals are male so
I support that man I support that all
right so yeah he's got an ex-wife I've
been married just a couple of months
tell me about it five daughters
yeah five daughters
um so a couple years ago when I came
into the situation
um him and his ex-wife were
uh co-parenting I I think a little too
well they they were still doing like
family things together and um so when I
came in I was like
yeah that's gonna change I don't
I'm not comfortable with like Christmas
at your ex-wife's house so things have
slowly kind of
why why are you uncomfortable with that
um
I'm not saying you shouldn't be I just
why
I think
the issue for me was his co-parenting
situation was polar opposite of my
co-parenting situation
um my ex-husband's bipolar and it's it's
really hard to manage and I've I've been
on my own
even when we were married since the kids
were born I was basically a married
single mom and so coming from that
situation into his situation where they
still do like pumpkin patch picking
together and
but she's in a relationship and he's in
a relationship it was
it was just uncomfortable
so that that you landed there I'm so
glad you got there it sounds like they
have figured out a way to be divorced to
move on with their lives and still be
adults for their kids
yeah mashed possibly is still too weird
um that's that that would be a whole
other conversation with them too just to
listen to How they've arrived at where
they've arrived but the number of people
I talk to across the country who cannot
earn yours most people end up in your
situation I cannot get my spouse to do
my ex to do anything remotely like an
adult or they're struggling with mental
health issues or they just disappeared
or whatever
what is it are you jealous of her and
it's okay if you are just be honest are
you jealous of her are you jealous of
their former relationship or do you love
her him and you're like is that weird
gnawing feeling that he had a thing with
her once like what what is it there's
definitely uh jealousy okay underlying
there
um but
we're related at today is
the relationship has dissolved and
there's no more co-parenting and it's
very her side our side and
um she's starting to be very childish
and being friends with the kids instead
of
being a team with us
and I think I I would assume on her part
that is because you know there are
issues there with me
well you you broke up their team you
said you said this team isn't can't play
like this anymore not with me in the
picture
and so the team she's gonna feel like
he decided that their co-parenting
Arrangement was no good and he picked
you over her
yeah and so part of the jealousy issue
was because when we first met he told me
early on that two months before he met
me she was she wanted him back and he
had said no okay so then I was
increasing the more uncomfortable
you know doing anything so let's let's
clear this up they are linked forever
right and by marrying him
you have to deal with her
yeah and so you can fight that forever
or you can make peace in your soul and
here's the deal if he goes back to her
one day let's say that happened it's not
going to but let's say it did
your paranoia and frustration and
jealousy and anger and I don't like that
none of that will help that it will only
accelerate it
I think that's where we've landed is
the things that she has done from the
beginning are wrong and offensive and I
have every right to be mad but where I'm
coming like what like what
um like when we first got together she
did a background check on me and
absolutely I would do the same thing I
would do the same thing
I want to know who's in the lives of my
kids absolutely
I don't think that's weird at all if she
hid it from you lied about it okay but
you have to understand you're like
you know what I mean would you trust
some strange woman with your kids like
you'd want to know right yes but I don't
think she like I don't think she needed
to share my debt like that was her
digging because she knows he's big into
Dave Ramsey and big on debt free that's
fine that's fine okay so she was she was
she handled that immaturely yeah but why
are you giving her a rent-free space in
your head yeah that's what my husband
gives up he says like I don't understand
how you could be so
stuck on something that happened two
years ago and it's like well it's
because she's kind of like a trigger at
this point and no you're allowing her to
why why are you giving her this power
what is it about her is she beautiful is
she rich is she wonderful I think what
is it
when you when you hold her up you see
yourself as less than why
laughs
um I don't necessarily see myself as
less than I I just feel like
there's things in the situation that I
can't control yes
and you can't control her deciding to be
friends with her kids
no and I can't control her like teaching
the kid like we're to a point where the
children see every single thing their
mom does is correct and every single
thing their dad does is wrong great yeah
that's a season and that will shift and
then one day it will be everything dad
does is the best ever and you're their
best friend and Mom's the worst
like it's not a competition at this
point
we're trying to raise well kids
who have grown up in trauma
and
um have a very confusing childhood
between whatever
one two three years led to a divorce and
then this weird we're still kind of a
family but not really and then mom's
with somebody else and then oh suddenly
dad's with somebody else like that's
trauma for kids
right and so if they connect with a
parent that's normal they're going to do
that trying to fight that or be
frustrated by that
is you comparing yourself why don't they
like me as much as her or why don't they
like us is our rules are but man that's
just that's just throwing angst into an
already angsty situation situation can't
control it if she's abusing them or if
she's
um not following the court orders or she
is making putting them in situations
where they're not safe yeah man I'm all
in on that
uh but if she just feeds a McDonald's
every time it's frustrating and
maddening and there's going to be a
re-entry point every time they come back
to your house
right or like Mom doesn't make us two
that I know but I do
yeah it's not necessarily that bad it's
it's things that we can't control like
like her sense of humor with them in my
opinion is abusive like she calls them a
failure and thinks that's funny
and you know if they don't perform well
at soccer she's like the mom that's the
loudest one they are going you're not
getting any dinner tonight and it's just
like they know they missed the goals
they
know these things what can you do about
that
nothing that's that's so where my
struggle is you can keep holding Tighter
and Tighter or you can let go
how
you got to practice that and number the
first thing you got to practice it but
before that actually that's the second
thing the first thing is you have to
decide to let go
and my guess is grow uh being in love
with somebody and being connected to
somebody and making kids is somebody who
had bipolar disorder meant you had to
drive everywhere for everything because
you couldn't depend on anybody but
yourself
and you were every bit his mother as you
were his lover and that probably started
way back when you were a little kid
and the the control that kept you alive
in that relationship and the control
that you had to exert over your life
when you were a kid
is what's choking the life out of your
current marriage
is that fair
yeah
so it's what we're doing is we have to
say Okay
um Justin Verlander was pitching and he
throws a million miles an hour
so I'm going to have to swing really
fast I don't have to make up my decision
quick as he goes into his wind-up and
then another pitcher is going to come up
there and throw a bunch of curveballs
Greg Maddox is going to come up and
pitch and he throws very slow but he
throws all like all this curved stuff so
I got to be a little more patient it's a
different I gotta approach this thing
differently
and right now control for you giving
that up letting go with that
um feels like you're gonna you're
exposing yourself to more hurt is that
fair
yeah
and what I want you just to step back
and look at the pictures it's the
control right now that's killing you
or
I'm a seven and my husband's a one yeah
yeah so he doesn't get it nope
your childhood sucked didn't it
I'm sorry
he can't get it unless you talk to him
about it have you talked to him about it
yeah a lot okay yeah okay he's great
so here's your practice
over time
it's feeling your body start to try to
grab control of situations that you
can't control
and holding your breath for about four
or five seconds as deep as you can
and exhaling and intentionally dropping
your shoulders pulling them down and
opening your hands up saying can't
control this one
and this hurts
here's what I can control and we're
going to go that route and what we're
going to do is just practice this
is that something you're interested in I
don't think you believe that you're
worth a peaceful life
um it's not that I don't believe it it's
just that
I shouldn't experienced it
so like when my husband and I first got
together and we would have conflict I
would like feel my body tempting and
like my fist in the air almost like
metaphorically because I Was preparing
for that fight yeah and whoever came so
I've slowly like
I don't have those kind of conflicts
with him we really never fight when we
do it is always about his ex-wife I I
would suggest Nikki you're always at War
always
he might not know he's fighting you do
there's an Asus score of one is going to
go through life pretty go lucky
yeah and uh well that stinks let's do
this
yeah I don't know if you're familiar
with like
Enneagram personalities
um he's a nine he's a peacekeeper and
I'm an eight I'm a fighter
[Music]
it's always so amazing how y'all find
each other it's so good
so he has this like uncanny ability to
like let things roll off his back and I
like keep score well you've had to okay
you had to
um
one other thing I I have argued with
some of the great leaders in the
Enneagram world I I don't believe that
those things are innate that we're just
wired for that I think there's a
combination of wiring and and experience
you've had to fight
because if you don't fight with an Aces
score of a seven you and I aren't
talking
right
you're you're strung out somewhere or
you're you're in jail or you're in a
you're dead right right you've had to
fight
you haven't been able to recognize that
the fighting that kept you alive is
blowing things up right now
here here's the the way through it and
for somebody with an Aces score of seven
if you haven't had trauma counseling
you're probably gonna need it
um I recommend anybody over a four go do
that
um but
the only way through it
I mean the only way to heal is to go
directly through it
that's the only path forward you want to
do something crazy call his ex-wife and
say you want to go to breakfast
I've suggested that so and that was
actually one of our arguments because
early on I was like why don't we just go
to dinner and like have a sit down and
kind of map this thing out with the four
adults you know in the room and he was
like no no no no and then his ex-wife
suggested it and he's like I think we
should do this
okay hold on hold on
[Laughter]
oh geez
so the way you just said that clearly he
listens to her more than you he's still
in love with her more than you I can't
I'm just his I'm just B Team
and the way I hear that is
when you suggested it he was like oh
honey I'm not taking you to War I don't
want to fight and then when she said she
was into it she he was like okay maybe
this would work out
but exactly what he said I hear that as
a husband trying to protect his new wife
who's a little bit um one Anarchist
um and realizing that we could we could
probably make this thing happen I don't
think you should go with him the first
time
I think you should go just you two
you two grown women and you start the
whole conversation with I have
completely screwed this up
try there and I get it the silence is
deafening right now it's so good because
you're like to hell with that I ain't
saying that to that crazy listen if you
walked in and said I screwed this up I'm
jealous of your marriage I come from
abuse I was married to someone with
bipolar so I've just been in chaotic
relationships and I just started trying
to control everything
and I recognize I love him and I love
those girls and by loving him and loving
those girls that means I'm going to be a
part of your life forever
and so I want to I want to restart
if you went in with that attitude she
would probably have to pick her jaw up
off the floor
and you paid for you pay for the meal
and you also by the way have your
shoulders down the whole time you're
just like consciously pulling them down
and you're just kind
the word for that is the the brene brown
special it's vulnerable she could roast
you she could burn a hole through you
with that sort of vulnerability
she could or
y'all could get to some relational
ground that y'all are never going to get
to unless one of you acts like an adult
and just takes a knee
and yeah that's kind of where I'm
struggling is because why what what has
worked over the last two years
nothing it's just getting worse
isn't it it is it is it is so stop
fighting it's not that's clearly not
working
it's not working if you were a doctor
you would have fired yourself
because this medicine isn't working
would you just try it and see what
happens
yeah oh yeah I definitely want
more than anything to just have like
inner peace and stop being at conflict
with the whole situation you were gonna
have that's you've got to get a
counselor here's why your body is gonna
have to practice peace because it's
never had it
it's it's a unicorn right now it's like
a mythological place you've never
experienced it
and you want it but you don't even know
what it is you don't even know what it
feels like and you're gonna have to
practice it and you're gonna have to get
somebody to walk with you
and when those girls when did your abuse
start
eating as a child or with my marriage as
a child
it's just it's never been
from day one like it's never been great
okay you've you're surrounded by five
girls
your body's alarm systems are going to
ring off the freaking hook right
yeah because it remembers that story of
what happens when you're a little girl
[Music]
so your job as the adult as the parent
of five little girls
is to go do the work to heal those
alarms and redirect them
because you don't want to pass that
trauma to them
you want them to be aware and smart and
bright and able to read a room and able
to keep themselves safe all those things
are good
but you can't do those things when your
body's under threat because it just says
get out of here
right and I don't want them to feel like
they have to choose that's right
so that that healing isn't something you
you tell them
it's something you do for you and they
absorb it they feel it
right is that fair yeah the only thing
in this whole situation you can you the
only person you can change is you that's
it
and it's just asking yourself is this
working and you and I both it's not it's
not
no it's not
and so I'm just suggesting try something
completely different if you take her to
breakfast and it goes it just goes off
the rails
just off the rails
um
you'll have learned something right
right you can say I tried that that
didn't work that was that was not good I
called some podcaster and he's an idiot
oh hey I will announce to everyone who
listens uh Nikki called me back and said
um she went on that breakfast and
her
husband's ex was it just ruined
everything it was a disaster I I will
I'll put that out to the world that's
fair I don't think that will happen
maybe it will but I don't think it will
and I'm not saying y'all gonna be best
friends you're not you aren't going to
be best friends you're not gonna call
each other and be like do you want to go
get pedicures that's not gonna happen
um I'm not gonna go hang out at TJ Maxx
do people shop Kelly TJ I don't know
no Kelly's more of a Carhartt gal what
I don't know people go shopping I'm just
saying you're not going to be shopping
partners
but you are gonna have to learn how to
do life together you're not gonna have
to figure this out and
it's just being an adult it's putting
away the immediate putting away the hard
stuff for the things that are right the
things that are best long term
um hang on the line here Nikki I'm going
to send you a copy of my book I want you
to read it from start to finish it's
about dealing with trauma it's a call in
your past change your future hang on the
line here I'm gonna send you a free copy
um please reach out to a counselor in
your community and say I'm ready
I had a rough go of it I've got a
marriage worth hanging on to now
um I've met a guy that's good I've got
five kids that I'm wrestling with I've
got a
um a blended family that I'm I've now
entered into I don't want to do this
right and I deserve to be well I deserve
peace I deserve
oh I'm gonna start there thank you for
being brave Nikki I'm grateful for you
let me know how that that breakfast goes